à 13 ans et demi pierre galy de sk sont
16 est un pilote de karting qui fait
parler de lui un surdoué qu'il ait du
temps ce qui se fait de mieux en france
dans sa catégorie
ça fait cinq ans qui roulait en cinq ans
il est devenu d'une des stars françaises
de ce sport cette année pour sa 1re
junior en kf3
il est pilote d'usiné pierre est monté
sur la troisième marche du podium au
mondial en italie bat même moi je m'y
attendais pas au début j'avais du mal à
réaliser et puis ça arriver comme ça
pour moi je pense que c'est c'est plus
du bonus pierre a profité bien c'est lui
qui conseille ses mécaniciens sont
préparés
aujourd'hui il est en sport-études au
mans la fédération française voit en lui
un futur grand champion
cette année il est dans le club du staff
trouve très bien
ces nouveaux programmes de détection qui
a été mis en place par effet fait ça et
qui regroupe pour l'instant si petit
français de 13 à 15 ans et on dit qu'il
pourrait rejoindre l'équipe de france il
serait alors le plus jeune de cette
formation
avec l'âge il est ambitieux il sait ce
qu'il veut son rêve un volant de formule
1 c'est un garçon malgré son âge qui a
déjà beaucoup de maturité fier et très
très mature il a encore de l'expérience
de course à avoir de temps en temps j'ai
fait des petites réflexions pour qu'il
fasse progresser sa façon de conduire
pendant les courses
toute la famille participe à la
progression du champion aujourd'hui pour
être au top niveau il ne lui manque pas
grand chose un peu d'expérience en
course internationale
actuellement il n'est que cinquième des
cheveux est fort soit rien est encore
joué il vise la plus haute marche du
poteau
[Musique]